l'état at-il fait du zèle deux ans
quasiment après le décès de son père en
plein confinement patrice dupas est
encore traumatisé ce loir et chérien ne
comprend toujours pas pourquoi les
gendarmes l'ont empêché de se rendre au
chevet de son père sur l'île de ré alors
que celui ci était mourant aujourd'hui
l'homme de 53 ans attaque l'état pour
obtenir réparation
samuel colin
le fameux courrier qu'on avait eues
l'attestation déplacement dérogatoire mi
mars 2020 les premiers jours d'un
confinement historique avec l'apparition
pour tous les français de ce bout de
papier sésame pour se déplacer pour
pascal dupas cette période coïncide
aussi avec une difficile nouvelle un
cancer généralisé
diagnostiqués tardivement à son père et
les forces sont en train de partir donc
un liban c'est ce week-end ou sait
jamais donc moi je rentre leur auditoire
jouer à madame ma femme et puis je lui
dis bah je vais faire l'aller-retour à
les murs et donc je pars le lendemain
matin avant de partir il s'assure d'être
dans les clous auprès de la gendarmerie
sur la route il passe un premier
contrôle arrivé à l'île de ré à moins de
deux kilomètres de sa destination
une quinzaine de gendarmes filtre les
passages malgré ces justificatifs l'un
d'entre eux ne veut rien entendre
je suis dit tiens c'est normal qu'ils
nous fassent mais c'est anormal km et
empêcher le d'aller le voir coiffer tout
en lui lisant le messenger il ne
comprend pas ce que je suis il a ma
belle mère au téléphone il n'écoute pas
il met mais une amende avec la
médiatisation de son histoire la mangue
sera annulée mais le tort n'est pas
oubliée loin de là son père sous
sédatifs décède trois jours plus tard
sans qu'il ne puisse le revoir pour
pascal dupas la préfecture est
responsable mais ne veut pas le
reconnaître je me sens moins coupable
de ne pas avoir pu passer
ces sales puants c'est pas le fait des
pas y aller oui mais c'est le fait de
dire mais qu'est ce que j'ai pas fait
qu'est-ce que j'ai mal fait pour
pas ne pas le voir encore une dernière
fois vivant quoi d'où ce recours contre
les représentants de l'état faut qu'il
se mette à ma place que ces gens
prennent la plume à ma position que ce
soit un de leurs parents qui est en
train de partir et qu'on leur a interdit
d'y aller et ce recours contre l'état
compte autant comme demande de
réparation que comme une démarche dans
son deuil